AND NONPORTS OF ENTRY.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US TONIGHT.
LAST OCTOBER, BY THE WAY, THOSE
CARAVANS WERE APPROACHING THE
U.S. BORDER.
ON THIS SHOW, I WARNED OF
SOMETHING THAT WAS BEING LOST IN
THE GREATER DEBATE.
WATCH.
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE, AN ECONOMIC ISSUE, COSTS
TAXPAYERS BILLIONS          BILI
TAXPAYERS BILLIONS          BILN
TAXPAYERS BILLIONS          BILS
TAXPAYERS BILLIONS          BILO
TAXPAYERS BILLIONS          BILL
TAKE ALL HIS PEOPLE ENTERED
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, HEALTH CARE, HOW
WE KNOW.
IT'S A HEALTH ISSUE TOO BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT PEOPLE HAVE
COMING IN HERE.
WE HAVE DISEASE IN THIS COUNTRY
WE HAVEN'T HAD FOR DECADES.
THE BACKLASH I RECEIVED WAS
SWIFT.
I WAS IMMEDIATELY VILIFIED FOR
SAYING SUCH A THING.
HOW DARE I.
THIS IS INSIDER CALLED IT A
CONSPIRACY THEORY IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAID IT
WAS DEHUMANIZING.
WELL, WOULDN'T YOU KNOW IT.
TODAY REUTERS REPORTED, OR
YESTERDAY, EXCUSE ME, THAT
OUTBREAKS OF INFECTIOUS DISEASES
AMONG MIGRANTS INCLUDING CASES
OF THE MUMPS, MEASLES,
ET CETERA, HAVE FORCED OVER
2,000 OF THEM INTO QUARANTINE
AND VARIOUS DETENTION CENTERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
SO MY QUESTION, WILL THOSE
CRITICS NOW GO AFTER REUTERS?
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS IT,
IT'S WAY BEYOND MUMPS.
MARC SIEGEL.
DR. >> , I WAS SLATED FOR
WARNING ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS A REAL HEALTH RISK TO
AMERICAN CITIZENS, ESPECIALLY
AMERICAN SCHOOLCHILDREN, IS IT
NOT?
>> ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THE IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT HAS HER HANDS FULL.
50,000 IN DETENTION CENTERS, AND
AS YOU JUST POINTED OUT, OVER
2,000 KNOWN QUARANTINE.
MUMPS TRAVELS THROUGH THE AIR.
MUMPS, YOU MAY NOT HAVE SYMPTOMS
AND YOU ARE SPREADING IT.
MEASLES AS WELL.
ALSO CHICKEN POX.
ALSO CASES OF TUBERCULOSIS BEING
FOUND.
YOU KNOW THE BIGGEST ISSUE IS
THAT THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL WILL SCREEN LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED INTO THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY UNLESS THEY
CHECK YOUR MEASLES MUMPS RUBELLA
TIGHTER, CHICKEN POX, YOU HAVE
TO PROVE YOU HAVE RECEIVED THE
VACCINE AND THAT IT'S
WORKING.
CDC TOLD ME TONIGHT THAT THEY
ARE PLAYING CATCH UP NOW.
ICE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CALL THE
ICE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CALL THM
ICE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CALL THO
ICE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CALL THT
ICE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CALL THE
ICE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CALL THQ
ICE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CALL THU
ICE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CALL THR
ICE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CALL THN
ICE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CALL THI
ICE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CALL THE
PEOPLE AND REVACCINATED THEM TO
CHECK TO SEE IF THEIR IMMUNE
STATUS IS THERE.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, CALLING
THIS A PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM.
A BIG PART OF THE PROBLEM, AND
IT TIES IN WITH NATIONAL
SECURITY.
MULTIPLE DISEASES ARE COMING IN
WITH THE MIGRANTS.
SPEAK TO DR. SIEGEL, WHEN
SOMEONE COMES IN AND YOU SAY
HAVE YOU BEEN VACCINATED?
HOW ARE ARE YOU WAY TO CHECK
THAT?
YOU CAN'T REALLY -- THERE IS NO
LEGITIMATE WAY TO CHECK.
HAS X, Y, AND Z GOTTEN THE
VARIOUS TECHNO SHOCK?
YOU CAN'T REALLY CHECK THAT,
RIGHT?
WE HAVE ENOUGH PROBLEMS WITH
PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY NOT BEING
VACCINATED, THAT BIG
CONTROVERSY.
BUT NOW WE ARE OVERWHELMED AND
THEY ARE GOING TO VILIFIED ALEX
AZAR AT HHS AND SECRETARY OF
HHS?
WHAT IS HE SUPPOSED TO DO?
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO DEAL
WITH IT.
HE'S LEFT TO PICK UP THE PIECES.
>> YOU NOT ONLY CAN'T CHECK IT.
YOU CAN TAKE SOME IS WORD FOR IT
BECAUSE OF COURSE THEY'RE GOING
TO SAY YES, MA'AM, HE ASKED HER.
BUT ALSO IT WEARS OFF.
THIS VACCINE WEARS OFF,
ESPECIALLY WITH MUMPS AND MUMPS
CAN CAUSE INFERTILITY, BRAIN
SWELLING.
THESE ARE NOT JUST MINOR
CHILDHOOD DISEASES WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
WE HAVE SEEN MEASLES RESURGENCE
MAINLY ACROSS THE BORDER AND
THEN PEOPLE THAT DON'T GET
VACCINATED, LIKE YOU SAID,
PEOPLE WHO REFUSE TO GET
VACCINATED, IT SPREADS LIKE
WILDFIRE TO THE UNVACCINATED
POPULATION.
THIS IS THREAT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
ALSO MOSQUITO BORNE DISEASES,
400,000 CASES OF MALARIA COMING
IN.
TUBERCULOSIS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THE LEFT
DOESN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT.
IT'S AN ACTUAL ISSUE.
>> Laura: AGAIN, BACK TO THE
POINT I MADE AND THE ANGLE.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO HAVE A
DEBATE ON THESE ISSUES BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T DEBATE IT.
ALL THEY CAN SAY IS YOU ARE
RACIST.
YOU ARE XENOPHOBIC.
YOU ARE DEHUMANIZING.
YOU'RE CRUEL.
YOU'RE MEAN.
THAT'S ALL THEY HAVE.
BECAUSE YOU GET DOWN TO THE
FACTS, THEY ARE PUTTING
AMERICANS AT RISK AND TRUMP AND
HIS POLICIES ARE ACTUALLY
GEARED, DR. SIEGEL, TOWARD
KEEPING OUR PEOPLE SAFE.
THAT'S HIS FIRST AND MOST SOLEMN
OBLIGATION, TO KEEP THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SAFE AND HE'S TRYING TO
DO THAT.
HE'S NOT PERFECT.
NONE OF US ARE.
BUT HE'S TRYING TO DO THAT.
>> LAURA, THE CDC WAS REALLY
NONPARTISAN, CALLS US PLAYING
CATCH UP.
THEY ARE IN THE COUNTRY AND THEN